boom what's up everyone hello welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saucon we
have a really exciting episode in guest
today my egg Herman hello it's a
pleasure to be here thank you so much
Thank You Alan yes Maya is really
awesome building really cool stuff into
the world we're excited to share with
you even of a demo it's gonna be really
fun so Maya's background is in computer
science doctorate at Waterloo and then
it became an assistant teaching
professor at Florida State University
Santa Clara University and founded and
CEO of wave AI which has a product
called Alicia right now which is a song
grading AI so really simply can just go
to try Lycia comm and type in lyrics and
then the AI will produce a melody for
you and then you own that music and
right now it's free yeah which is really
generous of you eventually we're gonna
have to we're gonna definitely pay so
that you can sustain the business can
sustain and we can keep I love look at
this logo it's a really cool very
futuristic and then the a music note
along with the human singing is really
nice oh thank you so much challenge yeah
we're excited to chat with you about all
of this so maybe tell us a bit about the
background how you actually you know as
you're at Waterloo were you thinking
like I want to be an entrepreneur you
know how did you get to where you're at
you know I think of all the different
career paths I've considered an
intrapreneur was never on the map
somehow originally I wanted to be a
product manager that was sort of my goal
going to university then I fell in love
with math in undergrad I just thought it
was the most amazing thing I don't know
if you ever heard of graph theory so you
basically have nodes and edges and you
can create all these structures and I
thought it was just the most incredible
thing on the planet I ended up doing my
masters in theoretical machine learning
had no idea that machine learning was
hot and when I was going to become this
revolutionary
that everybody learns whether they're
interested or not so um
Thunder 20 I continued that I've really
fell in love with research and with this
idea of making a real impact on the
academic community this thought that
there could be something in my mind that
nobody has ever thought before yeah that
I could really contribute something
brand new was just so exhilarating for
me yeah at the PhD student but around
the middle of my PhD there was a very
sharp turn when I started taking voice
lessons
just for fun on the side and you weren't
an opera singer before before your PhD
no no no so it's already had a family
and a child and I was doing my PhD and
you know people for some reason assumed
that everything you do you need to start
when you're five well I guess not yeah
and so I remember taking my first voice
lesson and realizing that I had so much
to learn and I would spend at least an
hour singing every day to the dismay of
my neighbors because I wasn't very good
at the time but after nine months of
working very very hard that I became
semi-professional I was really shocked
by my mind since semi-professional yeah
that's really impressive most people
can't get semi-professional in nine
months and anything that's really good
well thank you thank you that's it just
sort of happened you know people
suddenly were willing to pay for me to
sing so that was the shocking thing but
my life were completely disjoint there
was computer science which had nothing
to do with the arts at the time I was
doing theory basically blended in
computer science and math and then there
was singing music and very very human
way that was not really in any way
interacting with technology and it was a
little bit disorienting to be honest
four years
for about three to four years it was
just these two parallel lives it's not
interaction
then I was attending ITA it's a workshop
on information theory and applications
in San Diego there was a very small
segment about the arts as it relates to
information technology and I was
completely completely floored
I saw Harold Cohen who unfortunately
passed away recently
who created Aaron the system that paints
he created it before it was easy to do
he had these robot arms moving around
and he was standing there having an
argument with himself about whether or
not his Aaron is being creative or not
and I was just totally blown away I
didn't care if it was creative or not
but I just cared that somebody was so
passionate about this argument yeah
then there was Mark Bedell talking about
a storytelling system and they sure are
talking about the music system I waited
until everybody left and I followed them
until they told me a whole bunch of
stuff about computation with creativity
and where do I learn more and so over
the summer I went to the international
conference and computational creativity
having no publications their
international conference on
computational creep oh yeah is every
year it is mind blow wait where is it
well it's different places just you know
what's going to be in Spain cool yeah so
I'm gonna be in Spain in June awesome in
June this time are the first time that's
a great place to bring simulation to go
and talk to all these brilliant people
maybe we should figure out how to do
that that sounds so cool cuz like you
were describing seeing and a robot
painting
and then the having the person arguing
is it being creative right now I can't
who is it
etc and then having that with other
things like songwriting and all the
computational creativity the essence of
that so cool oh yeah it's it completely
transformed my life I was like this
exists it has occurred to me to combine
art or music with computers I just had
no idea there was a meaningful way to do
it that would actually be worth my time
by the way about Harold Coyne he was
standing there essentially screaming
that other people were saying that his
system was creative and he was the own
voice of reason saying that it's not
worth taking live theatre is really just
so so inspiring the passion yeah so yeah
you should definitely go to the
conference you'd need all these just
brilliant brilliant minds yeah so on the
way to the International Conference on
computational creativity I spilled I
believe it was tea on my laptop and so
my laptop was dead and so I go to the
first talk and I don't have anything to
distract myself with and so I just sit
there and listen mm-hmm I guess we
should all do that and completely in
passing the speaker mentioned so that
obviously we don't have to think about a
computer as just a tool you could be a
co-creative partner perhaps in a human
yes and there's all what I was just
reading about alpha zero as well as that
the way that it's thinking in new
dimensionalities like sacrificing a
queen and a bishop to gain a positional
advantage it's like an alien playing
chess the way that a human can co-create
with that at the same time to learn and
then have the eye assess the human
assist it cetera that can very
applicable to all this computational
creativity and songwriting and all these
other artistic forms so that's really
exciting that hybrid of those two
exactly you are you're absolutely right
you know it's this was the first time I
was introduced to the concept but since
then exactly that you're saying I'm
hearing more and more people express a
combination of human and machine that's
a real powerhouse yeah as a real
direction not only because as humans
don't want to be left behind but because
that's how we achieve real greatness hmm
so that's that that's instant everything
change for me you know those pivotal
moments in life yeah yeah I've been
trying to write original songs for years
as a musician and it never occurred to
me that a computer could be helpful for
that
the moment ahead the idea it became so
obvious to me that it's possible to do
it so I got home I talked to David who's
one of our co-founders right now and
within three months we had a very early
prototype tour and I could write songs
it was this mind-blowing experience that
just words us input just words as input
now the backgrounds great and it totally
makes sense how you got into
computational creativity maybe you teach
us a bit about how I write in a word and
then how this do we pick with a certain
amount of confidence what note would
work well with the word how does this
work how did this work for a good
question I like it that you have this
insight into machine learning so yes
machine learning is fundamentally about
prediction so the classical example or a
lot of the money that goes back to the
stock market let's predict is a stock
going up or down let's predict if you're
gonna want to listen to a particular
song or watch a particular movie in
prediction how do we take machine
learning which is geared towards
prediction and use it to generate use it
to create instead well the track is
actually pretty simple we're gonna ask
you to predict the next note how can I
agree with it then we're gonna ask it
now predict the next note mm-hm and
we're gonna agree with it again and
that's how it ends up generating now of
course there's a lot of subtlety in here
because if it always predicts the same
thing we could only ever get one melody
out of it so the way that you build the
model you want to make sure that you get
a lot of exploration yeah okay and let's
say that we write lyrics like I love San
Francisco let's say those are forward
lyric for now now how do
you assign a certain note to I to love
to San and to furthest Francisco that's
right so um it's a simplest way to
assign one note per syllable for
syllable for syllable that's right yeah
you know we don't always do that so
there's like six six or not okay those
kinds it's the basic approach now
sometimes it's not what you want
especially in some water in John Rizzo
want multiple notes four syllables
sometimes an operand you want to say
it's on front see he's cool no it's just
hurtful you gotta get a little bit more
of that that's good so in principle he's
not-it's not always think it's not a
hard person but that's that's a basic
model okay alright let's let's meet
let's go through a demo let's all
wonderful yeah no keep going for a bit
and then we'll go through the demo yeah
yeah you'd be just for the introduction
teaching assistant professors means
something different than assistant
professor in the crazy means that you
don't do research and that's what you
and it's not what I am your assistant
teaching professor there's no teaching
us isn't professor yeah yeah yeah okay
verso you because you do AI research I
do anything Scalia so for most people is
gonna make no difference but just for
academic academic they know the
difference and they'll think that it's a
lesser role yeah assistant professor
means you do research teaching assistant
professor means you don't do mean you
just each yeah oh okay so if it's okay
what could we do just yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly
or even now like what we just said I
think we'll be okay but I and will write
in the bio the difference but yeah yeah
I'd appreciate if you a little one
sentence
yeah no it's okay no it's really okay
okay so are we what do you think we're
on in terms of time for the yeah let's
do it
there any way to touch it because I have
a more recent version of this one-day
sale where I can just enter like
tomorrow so we can do that yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
craziness don't make me they is that for
your makes me sick wanna know yours oh
no you can't afford the big tits in it I
mean explain me my baby
quite a bit but not enough to give you
up they got a pious feel no wrong with
the nights but I bet on you every time
you climb on the grime I know you keep
me right over the shop it makes you even
say find my sensor you get higher you
try to time with you like it's a
cloaking field but you try
[Music]
cool so alright so we see there's a lot
that's going into this there's a lot so
someone decided to write those lyrics
and then you guys decided to figure out
what were the right and you said there's
a version with drums as well so there's
all these synths there's what piano
there's guitar there's drums there's all
these different options that you can add
in as the notes so how do you also pick
between the instruments that's right so
um instruments well have you seen how
the system works no no should I do that
that would be that would have to be
really great together
can we pull up the web browser and go to
trial SEO comm pre-production so it's
okay we'll do it we'll do it soon
well we'll get better at this over time
so okay we'll do some pre-production
stuff next time we'll get you to see
what's actually going on with trial SEO
calm but in the meanwhile well you know
the links in the bio so you can always
go to trial easy calm and check this out
yourself but let's get just a verbal
explanation oh yeah so the way it works
is you come in and you type in lyrics
and then Elysia gives you many different
options for that line of lyrics so in
particular gives 25 options - we've
selected from the hundreds that we
generate in the background and then I
can go and listen to these different
options see what feels best that's right
yeah because ultimately you're the
creator the computer is there to help
fill in things that are they're
difficult for us as we don't specialize
in or just to save time so you type in
your first line of lyrics pick a melody
for that and then there are various ways
you can tweak the melody as well and
then you type in your next line and
again select a melody for your next line
cool piece it together like a puzzle and
other reasonable people who've never
written a song before who've never
touched the musical instruments can
write the vocal line for an original
song then you can pick an instrument for
it add drums and eventually roll over
the next few weeks you'll be able to add
the chord progressions the flesh of the
song as much as possible
okay so the general idea is that I write
a couple a lyric at a timer a kind of a
set of a phrase at a time of sentence at
a time of the lyrics and then I get 25
different options of what you guys
predict would sound good with that I get
to pick the one that I think's best and
then we go on to the next line
the next phrase now hmm would there
typically be a wouldn't there be a
scenario where if I pick let's say one
of the 25 that sounds the best that the
first line and then what the second line
it would probably be something close to
what the first line to what I picked for
the first yeah then you learn and you
pick there you choose like maybe 25 that
sounds some what's exactly exactly there
based on your choices from the first one
to the second one because otherwise it
would be the 25 different ones it's just
be all over the place all over the place
that's right and you also have the
option of taking an existing sub milites
and replicating it intentionally putting
in repetition okay so it's like turning
something really complicated into some
things that only relies on your ability
to tell whether you like it or not oh
cool you don't have to generate anymore
computers are amazing and generating
they're not as good at evaluation but
humans are amazing at evaluation
somebody who has absolutely no musical
experience can tell if they like a song
or not yeah and so that's that's where
it's a collaboration I love that that we
have the capacity to feel and like
evaluate way more than we do to be able
to actually write the song with all the
different complexities and instruments
and melodies and all that stuff so cool
well I remember when I was trying to
write songs and I'd really put in a lot
of effort I took improv lessons in piano
improvisation they've got a whole bunch
of books my problem was is that I simply
wouldn't come up with enough interesting
variation
I had a really hard time exploring the
space and the computer you know when
you've set it up right it's just so good
at it yeah and takes a lot of that
workload off of our brain of figuring
that out and then we get to just feel
and evaluate like and sometimes I test
the software or I do a little demo for
somebody and it's just so beautiful I
just keep it and then expand it into a
whole song yeah man okay so what is the
what how many songs have currently been
generated oh it's in the thousands we've
had a war of about six seven hundred
people on Alysia right now cool and
there are so many songs being created
every day but very recently actually
just a Saturday we had a contest that
has ended yeah we saw definitely when we
roll out our lyrics maker over the next
few weeks we'll have a subcomponent of
élisa élisa lyrics it'll make it very
easy to write lyrics and once we have
that we'll have a second content lyrics
maker as in the as in because if the
lyrics are being chosen as well then
what role do I even have just evaluating
which one sounds good with the lyrics
and the melody and then picking that and
keep going and picking because if I'm
not even writing the lyrics then well
then what are you doing but there's so
much to songwriting that goes just so so
much you need to write the lyrics need
to write the melody need to write the
overall structure of the song to the
drum track produce the song sing the
song hardly anybody can do all of this
yeah so for me I'm the singer I would
personally be happy if somebody else to
care of everything else and I would just
sing but that doesn't mean that
everybody wants that yeah somebody else
might be a poet they don't want help
with that part somebody might have no
problems coming up with melodies in fact
a lot of people that I talk to struggle
with melody writing and then there's a
whole separate group of people who
struggle with lyrics but just like with
a melody writing we're not trying to
give you fully cooked lyrics
it's an iterative process in fact the
version that we're considering right now
I've had an early prototype last year
where I type in one line of lyrics and
then I have Elysia proposed 25 options
for the next line of lyrics and then for
each subsequent one I can either have at
least a proposed annex one or if I want
to I can order to interject my own ideas
I can alter what Elysia gave we're not
doing this to serve the AI as AI serving
us so we only use it as much as it's
helping us create what we want yes cool
so we're constantly even if the lyrics
are being generated and giving us
options and melodies are being
generating us options we're doing the
evaluation and we're picking out what we
think would sound and feel good for us
why should we really need that humans
are another weakness of machines
especially when it comes to generation
is there much behind humans when it
comes to big-picture stuff especially it
was text generation but if a human is in
the loop for humans it's so easy to tell
if sentences fit together if they make
sense as part of a whole yeah exactly
yes the exactly these weaknesses will
soon also be more glottal to be less
prevalent they'll be
I'm wondering when the human gets out of
the loop of songwriting in general oh
that's a really good question and I
think people feel so passionately about
it and I completely understand why I
think that polecat first of all as far
as creating background music so songs
without lyrics there's a long history in
the research community of automated
systems writing complete musical songs
but without without any lyrics without
any singing there is early work where
David cope from Santa Cruz imitating the
style of bark and involved in creating
beautiful music so to some degree this
happened but a very small degree we
don't have any computer generating
generated songs on the radio and we
won't anytime soon I think it's a matter
of emphasis it's sort of a matter of
what we're looking for in the quality
that we're going for as far as where we
get the best results we get it by
collaborating with machines not by
having them go beginning to end but
there is progress being made in that
direction as well because that's what
some people are interested in that's
what they they focus on as well so right
now there's several a hundred people
using this 1,000 and it's going well do
you wend what do you foresee asked some
of the new additions you said the lyric
generator is a new addition into it what
are the other kind of additions that
you're thinking about putting in there
what chord progressions we're working on
that right now so both the lyrics chord
progressions we have developers focusing
on both of these because then you come
in and you can have help with each one
of these really complicated things and
really letting you focus on the parts
that you like most and eventually
eventually for those who want that kind
of support we want to be able to create
the entire background track Oh another
very very important thing is if a
producer already created a background
track we want to be able to take that
background track feed it into Alicia and
have Alesia create the vocal melody on
top of that
mm to support yet the other direction
yeah yeah huh there so because there are
so many instrumentals that don't have
lyrics over them which is interesting
because you could just plug those in and
see what the AI thinks would work well
as lyrics although those instrumentals
okay what about what about a
monetization model what are you thinking
to be able to sustain the business well
I think it's if we can we're always
gonna keep a freemium something that's
available for everybody because
ultimately the Internet and a lot of
technologies about making great things
available for everyone definitely and to
whatever degree possible we're gonna
have a lot of things that are available
for free people will come in and play
and if they can't afford to pay for
anything then they don't need to for
people who want the more advanced
features who want access to everything
all the time
we're probably gonna be looking at a
subscription model like 10 a month or 20
a month or that's to be determined yeah
yeah that's fair I think so especially
for people that want to use more
features there might even be a tiered
you know $10 a month version then maybe
25 a month for people that really want
everything and direct contact with your
team all that cool stuff so yeah I mean
in principle we can do amazing things we
can take what we have and we've done
that in the past we've retrained it on
the music of you como Puccini and we
created Italian Aria out of it so that's
something that we could also make
available as a service
oh yeah it's people could pay you
thousands of dollars to go and parse
music sets from around the world
and then you could create the platform
for them to use with their cultural
music set that they like exact same it
can go different human languages there's
a lot of opportunities for people who
want to dig dig very deep primarily
musicians but then we want it to be
accessible to everybody wanted to be
also useful for everybody so that
somebody who has no musical expertise
whatsoever could still come in and
express themselves creatively
helps us make a song for their loved one
what what do you what do you think about
the current state like let's okay let's
talk about what would shun Reserve music
you typically have right now oh I think
what genre can be used with Alicia
before well what a very interesting
thing that I learned is that there is
some flexibility in the relationship
between melodies and genres so when you
talk to composers they would often tell
you that if a melody is genuinely good
then it will work in many different
genres and we've seen examples of that
in the past because a lot of the genre
comes from the way that the singer sings
it the kind of background music doesn't
include drums how faster the background
music going what instruments are chosen
and this is just so central to the genre
that it ends up sounding like yeah that
being said it is also interesting for us
to consider subgenres separately at one
point at one point we had and this year
trying on pop and it rained on Puccini
music which we started exploring early
because I sing opera la langue Puccini
so and then we accidentally blended them
how was that and I was like I'm thinking
to myself what is this I can't tell
which do you think actually really good
I think mixed model and people aren't
doing this in the world pop and opera
there's also this cool computational
creativity might lead us down mixing
genres that we would never thought of
before exactly so we are going to offer
separate genres and ultimately the
ability to blend them as well so
interesting currently it's trained on a
mixed bag of primarily pop I'm merely
popping pop rock a few genres that work
all together what do you think about the
current culture of music right now
there's so much of the
you know money and sex and drugs and
stuff involved in our music scene what
do you think about the current status of
that in ten oh we're it's transitioning
to does your AI predict like sex and
[ __ ] and like all those like but we're
dealing with lyrics right now yeah he's
just talking to my co-founder David who
is focusing on this project and he says
you know we're gonna have to censor so
we're gonna need to make some choices
around that that's interesting that you
picked up on that yeah definitely know
there's some choices that you'll have to
make now that I think of it perhaps that
should be the users choice if they would
want language like that or not under my
food should be making that decision for
users long term but perhaps at first to
a night sensor it more heavily to not
you know not mislead or maybe just have
the Select on or off feature yeah I
would keep mine always on for always on
so that I could get the dirty lyrics you
know a dirty version you know it's
reminded me of doing some research was
Rafael Paris of Paris actually
fascinating man you should meet him
and we were looking at we created this
lyrics maker together also is my student
divyam and we were comparing some other
system to ours and there's this
wonderful system there's actually a few
of them that writes lyrics for rap in
particular and humans found it to be
more emotionally engaging I think it's
just because we thought about it for a
long time what is it about rap lyrics
and these rapid lyrics generation is
that makes people feel something well
the language the words are so
provocative that we can't help but feel
something which could perhaps explain
why there are so much prevalence of it
in popular culture because it's so much
easier to provoke emotion if we can
resort to languages but on the other
hand it also represents what people are
feeling and perhaps it's
helps them expand their repertoire in
general maybe we can choose words that
hit people's emotions and that expand
their consciousness to new dimensions of
thought that's exciting stuff that I
care about a lot how can we put lyrics
into music that are really impactful
yeah yeah we we thought else about
intentionally creating socially
impactful music I love that idea that
could be another filter to turn on
that's cool
Huckabee that would be definitely very
feasible and I think I would I would
love to you know to support certain
causes like you know the environment we
could write songs about the environment
then you take a big corpus of the
language that's used in social activism
and then that's kind of what they eye
learns off open it plugs even though
really amazing thing is you can train
your system on lyrics and then have it
lean towards the environmental corpus
it's sort of blend okay yeah so but it's
still lyrics but suddenly it's more
likely to talk about the environment
yeah yeah okay all right so maybe a
little bit more on how it works because
it's a really interesting to understand
so how many voices are there that the AI
would choose to sing with okay so
currently it's more of a composition aid
so we do have we recently added some
soundfonts I think there's about 12 of
them you call it a sound font sound font
beautiful word right cool yeah we're
working with with dusty actually the guy
who produced the music okay yeah so
elysia composed and then he produced
yeah so he's made a whole bunch of sound
fonts for us and we're making one with
my voice that would sing you know
whatever the melody is it would sing it
on an ah yeah yeah it's really fun but
the user picks the sound phone and of
course ultimately and now that you're
saying this I think it would be
interesting if they I could suggest
which sound font would go well with a
particular song yes
so moving into hopefully like a dozen
soundfonts or so for for people to be
able to select yeah that's that's all
that's right now but on the other hand
you can also download it in MIDI format
open it up in GarageBand FL studios
whatever is your favorite DAW and
produce in any way you like
hmm oh so I can take the file you give
me and open up what how you put things
together and then move things around
myself exactly so for those for those
viewers who know how to produce yeah
it's designed to support this that's
good very modular then yeah for people
to take the content you make and then
then we were looking into shortly
creating some some plugins there to plug
right into their digital audio
workstation what would that look like oh
yeah into into gradual studios and it's
right there so the production and the
composition they they get joined mm-hmm
and then a it's you you know the
producer slash songwriters that's really
that's a gold standard to be able to do
everything
okay so all right let's do a little bit
more on how it works
so
I write the I love San Francisco
and then after I write that then you how
do you assign to each syllable how does
it learn what no would best go how does
it pick those first 25 that I get to
then listen to that's right so it learns
from existing songs you'd go through
hundreds of thousands of examples and so
if if it's so it's aw I love and then it
heard all the times that it said that in
different songs it was used I love I
love I love and then it can kind of
picked well I think you're getting
exactly the right idea exactly except
that we have to be a little bit careful
because while I love might appear
hundreds of times
this plant is tall might not yeah and we
need to be able to give melodies no
matter what the user gives us even if
it's an exceptionally rare word and so
the way deep learning works is could
utilize a combination of features so
some of the features can figure out by
itself with other models you need the
user to provide the features so you
would tell the system what kind of stuff
should be looking for and then the model
itself takes your advice into
consideration of what features it should
be considering and it decides ultimately
what's important are the previous notes
important is it important that the word
is common or not things like that
okay yeah that that makes less and so it
takes into account the context like we
were talking about this Pareto
distributions of words
how do we mention the proto distribution
yet no that was in the previous just
that two o'clock we mentioned Pareto
distributions is very very much so
directly applies to linguistics and what
you're doing Georgia from Harvard came
up as if slaw and if it follows a Pareto
distribution of that the things like
eighty percent of all of language is
only twenty percent of all words like of
and to which yeah so that makes it
easier than for you to
know what 20% of words are most used in
lyrics and then the harder words are the
ones that are less used like quiz
anxiously and like things like that well
the interesting thing is that music
often focuses on the rare words yeah so
it's whenever you have you know boring
words like articles they're rarely
emphasized but then once you have the
word you just mentioned there's no way
you could have it in there without some
interesting melody on top of it yeah
it's like four syllables yeah if
songwriter chooses to add an interesting
word they will often emphasize it and
that actually something that we learned
mmm through building elysium that being
said you have words like love that
appear over and over again
on which it's easier for a release here
to do a good job because see lots of
examples yep and then okay so words that
have more examples that Alicia has
learned from and the learning data set
comes from where so there are a lot of
songs out there so we're actually
building out a new corpus right now
there's gonna be you know just for us
but originally we were lucky to find
some existing research datasets oh cool
from a whole bunch of science a very
large data set about 6,000 songs after
that what that's really helped us kind
of push Elysees along but right now
we're stepping back and rebuilding our
own data because ultimately everything
starts and ends with high quality data
yeah yeah you can only learn as well as
information that you receive right yeah
created exactly yeah yep what are you
choosing to learn yes we're gonna yeah
we're gonna definitely have you know a
good corpus for very popular genres
that's that's the most important that's
going to be our initial focus but
ultimately the longer we do it the more
we'll be able to offer yeah okay and
then
all right so now we have the Isle of San
Francisco we see that love is used so
many times I San Francisco is used and
then maybe quiz Asia sleaze used way
less than the other one so it's more
difficult to find the right notes for
every syllable it doesn't mean it's more
difficult because okay the learning is
more complicated than that
it doesn't memorize that's very very
important machine learning models don't
memorize so if all it did was to go
through the corpus and look at how often
it saw certain words it would only be
able to perform well in those cases that
would be memorizing the whole point is
it can extract general principles so
that if you give it stuff you've never
seen before it can still do a good job
okay that's really key yeah yeah the
general principles are key exactly it's
about the learning what can be
generalized and actually machine
learning people all of us I teach my
students you make sure that your model
doesn't over fit because if it's
overfitting it means it's memorizing and
the way that you evaluate it in case
you're curious this is cool guys you
always keep out some time part of the
data you intentionally don't learn on it
and then you check how well it your
model doing on this held out set yeah
compared to the training set and if
there's a big gap then you're just
memorizing mm-hm yeah we want to avoid
that at all costs
yeah so you want there to be a little
gap well he want this little gap as
possible because you wanted to do nearly
as well on the data that it has not seen
because that means it's not memorizing
it can handle data it hasn't seen about
as well as its handling data that it has
seen mm-hmm so it's not overfitting yeah
this is really really key yeah you don't
want it to over fit you want it to
either fit or like slightly under fit
what you wanted to generalize the
opposite of overfitting is generalizing
just relearning meaning that it learned
it didn't memorize it learned some
general principles because think about
it machine learning is backwards usually
you go to a math class it give you the
rules and then you apply the rules of
specific examples from the rules to data
machine learning is backwards you got
the data you're making up the rules so
we need to make sure that these never
have to use the word rules carefully
right good it's machine
learning the machine learning system is
figuring out it's a generalization
exactly a generalization because of
world rules have another meaning in
computer science but it's figuring out
how to how this data was created and so
we want to make sure that this
generalizes to brand new data very well
and that's a key the only thing that
matters is how well it generalizes it
doesn't matter how well it does on data
that it has seen that it has learned on
mm-hmm
so when new data is input it into Alisha
then you try and see how well you can
generalize well we check it ourselves
before you have before giving it to
people who were very very thoroughly
check how well it does on data is that
it has not not warmed so you have a team
that looks at the new data that's input
into oh it's the same the same as you
learning people yeah that's aw they're
looking at it and seeing how well you
fit generalizations of music melodies
and even lyrics soon to data that has
not been seen absolutely because that's
that's everything cool yeah okay I get
to teach a little is she learning I love
it yeah very basic 101 I teach machine
learning at Santa Clara ok and
so so for fur let's say for a word like
you know San Francisco let's say that
how do you how do you figure out if you
want to add a piano or a drum or which
instrument work so we don't do that
right now we just don't right we focus
on composition because I mean there are
many different solutions for that we do
eventually want to get to automatic
production for the people who don't
specialize in production so that they
perhaps maybe they'd like to come up
with lyrics they type in their lyrics
they could piece together the melody and
then we could produce a whole background
track for them that would be nice down
the line but right now with their our
digital audio workstations that are
fantastic fantastic tools for picking
instruments for flushing out songs okay
that's kind of our initial focuses on
people who enjoy the production aspect
and who are looking for assistance with
composition yeah okay it's down the line
though down the line of course yeah we
want to make it dumb you want to empower
people as much as possible um
and I think I think people will always
want and will always benefit from
engaging as much as they can and are
able to but that amount is very
different for different people
yeah look I'm a singer I don't
necessarily want to Vocaloid to sing for
me yeah but there are other people who
Vocaloid it's a very cool part of music
technology something that sings seems
like a human it's it's amazing he's the
first one song font or sound font is
that how the instrument sounds yeah this
is Vocaloid for singing so you would
have to give it the melody and the words
and it would sing it for you they're
really really good in Japan and you know
they the English market is gradually
getting better Wow
but then somebody else maybe they're not
a singer and they could really use
technology to help them with that so we
sort of need to be as inflexible to the
fact that people need help in different
areas and we shouldn't be helping them
with what they don't want but we should
be helping them with where they welcome
to help worlds do you see
computational creativity especially what
you're making where else can it be
plugged into computational creativity is
enormous I love the part that intersects
with art I think it's just so amazing
that computers and AI can meaningfully
interact in the art world and
meaningfully help people it's it's
mind-blowing for me so there's a lot of
war going on a visual art there's an
amazing system called the painting fool
painting the painting form the painting
fold fool for EM fool the painting fool
[Applause]
doesn't know it's a computer oh that's
that's what I'm looking at it yeah it's
created by Sonya Colton and the works of
the painting fool have been displayed in
galleries and even commissioned for half
the amounts whoa it's a whole universe
out there is it digital art or is it uh
Wow
well like I can show you some of the
work that looks fun easy some of it
looks like paintings and what's really
amazing really amazing to me is that
some of the art that the painting fool
create would be very hard for a human to
do why it's something that has to do
with very regular patterns that keep
repeating in a very very small scale
yeah yeah we keep zooming in and keep
seeing that same pattern it takes a lot
of time for a human well it's just the
amount of how small they can go yeah and
then for example if you're drawing a
circle really small and then you're
slowly increasing the size of the circle
as you move downward maybe you're making
scales or something like that right
that's right it doesn't really make
sense for humans to do stuff like that
not anymore
yeah but humans can focus on the kind of
art that fits who we are we're different
awesome computers are different our
intelligence our creativity is different
it doesn't directly compete it's you
know as humans it's so nice to imagine
that we own intelligence we own
creativity yeah but that's a limiting
perspective there are other beings
computers included there are
intelligence and
in a different way than us and that's
okay that's beautiful yes I am so
curious to computational creativity
taking a strong position or a position
of
excellence in InDesign so that that's so
interesting to me because once the
computational creativity is to a
threshold that is acceptable by humans
as you know beautiful or as
well-designed once it gets to that point
then we can let we can let Leisha
computational creativity on how to how
to make the best coffee table well there
has been a little bit of work in the
direction there was I think it was
during the first International
Conference on computational creativity
that I attended that the speaker passed
out little vases and they were different
vases that their system designed and the
PAP has a tangible this becomes so
interesting because then with this
creative design the best digital
marketing assets don't preclude anyone
else from having it so then all of a
sudden you're you're have a new logo or
a new website or have a new ad or a new
banner or photo or whatever that is
beautiful that you didn't even require
human it's a design world didn't require
human to to be a part of it something
about what you're describing we saw this
election right we still have that that
part of the end which is that we think
that it's good value and then humans
decide that it's well done and then
that's right that's right so we wait we
definitely don't want to don't want to
cut the human out of the loop but when
it comes to logo that's really struck me
when you suggested that because there is
so much context that has to be
understood for a logo yes which reminded
me of the world's first mutational
creativity musical mmm which took place
in London about a year ago and they had
actually salmon colton's the guy who
created the painting fool his system
came up with the main idea for the
musical so kind of a one line one line
that's like a tag for what the musical
is about
- that was done by machine and then lots
of other components of the musicals were
also done by by machine including
various components of the music at least
I didn't exist it was still very early
at the time so you know the lyrics and
the melodies weren't integrated there
were other systems that were used the
various components and the human
musicians had to do a lot of the work as
well
potential creativity was also used I
believe to create the overarching
storyline of the musical so they really
try to put in as many systems as
possible which was on the one hand
amazing and on the other hand showed us
how much room for growth there is yeah
because in that process the computer was
sometimes helpful and sometimes a
hindrance and we obviously don't want
the latter what's the point right
it was very interesting but it has this
sort of like needing to understand
context element to it which I think
would be required for a lot of design
issues yep yep you nailed it context
will be a major aspect of how to design
or whatever the creativity is it has to
learn what is the data set that the
context is based on and then how can I
learn from that be familiar with conv
conv yeah conv it's yeah I don't believe
that there is any there's no I iein aid
that I'm aware of but they've definitely
made design of brochures or oh yeah it's
designed like visual design they did
paper they made it so much more
accessible calm right is that the same
and yeah I've clicked through they're
different
yeah brochures and there's all these
different templates kind of totally
excellent yeah it is good
I agree sometimes it's not about I love
AI don't get me wrong but I think it's
important sometimes to realize that it's
not about us serving the AI it's not
about us taking whatever they I happens
to get em hmm but rather what do we
really need well how do we want
computers to help us and what are the
best methods to get us there yep and
sometimes it's not AI and that's or at
least it's not AI right now and that's
okay how can we better understand
ourselves as good as well yeah
okay so okay that's good that's
computational creativity seems like
creativity is a major aspect of
us making great leaps and strides and
advancements in AI actually it being
creative or having other features of
what perceives to be consciousness Oh
consciousness sorry it's just heart of
so many words if we don't understand
yeah and we were only forced to examine
them at least you know in my case and
you know some people in my world who
don't focus on consciousness until
somebody questions whether a I can ever
have it they have no idea what
consciousness is
we don't sure maybe some philosophers
are a little bit closer to us than maybe
I am since they don't specialize in it
but as humanity all we know is the
experience all I know that I'm conscious
I have no idea if you're conscious I
have no idea if anybody is conscious
ever ever was conscious because we can't
define it properly we can't break it
down it's considered often to be an
emergent property if it's an emergent
property why can't it emerge out of a
very complicated AI with many components
correct
I feel like I'm just being honest
I said conscious the discussion about
consciousness is heavily premature every
day I yeah yeah do you do concern
yourself with ethics around oh how its
programmed what are your thoughts about
yeah we don't need any consciousness to
cause a lot of damage to human that can
be done without consciousness
we've seen did that that's a very good
point and actually Santa Clara
University really focuses on ethics and
they got me thinking about a lot of
these questions I'm actually designing a
course on artificial intelligence that
I'm gonna be starting to teach in two
weeks
cool approximately so I've been thinking
about a lot of these questions they're
fresh in my mind
I think with something as powerful other
artificial intelligence there is so much
responsibility but the responsibility I
think it's very important to note and
that's where my opinion differs from
some other people that I respect the
responsibility is not entirely on the
people who created artificial
intelligence the responsibility is on
society as a whole
perhaps the biggest challenges come
around job loss with things like
automated vehicles which is a very
complicated system in the course there's
a lot of benefit to come from automated
vehicles but I think how we transition
from a road full of humans to a road
full of
humans that are not driving anymore that
transition needs to be done gracefully
in our economy the way that it's driven
it's beautiful thing our economy gives
rise to amazing things like automated
vehicles but companies are incentivized
to grow very very heavily into
incentivize in fact if they don't grow
they disappear so pretty much all major
players try to grow as much as possible
and as a result it becomes essential
that government entities or perhaps some
other emerging entities in society help
people who lose jobs as a result of AI
or any other development help them
re-educate help them stay productive
members of society whether it be so
Universal income whether it be store
aggressively education contains but one
way or another as a society it's our
duty to take care of each other
with or without a I know first of all
it's about us humans taking care of
ourselves in our world and I think you
know as much as AI can help with that
that's great but process happened so
quickly that sometimes we need other
form of support to make sure that we
don't have you know a lot of negative
consequences do you think that's gonna
be part of what you teach oh definitely
yeah how are you gonna teach yeah go a
little deeper into how you're gonna help
teach ethics to the in in programming to
my students heart I think the whole
concept of pausing and thinking about
the impact off the software that we are
creating is not something that we're
trying to do there is over optimism
among software developers machine
learning engineers etc about the utility
of progress overall I mean I'm a big fan
of progress I'm a researcher anything
that has not been done I mean for me
it's almost a prerequisite for getting
excited is that it's brand new and
hasn't been done before I don't know how
it get excited about something that's it
but we should also another dimension it
was progress it's thinking well what is
this what's gonna happen after it's
built how's it gonna incorporate in
society how can i pivot what I do is the
most positive way possible right so it's
a difference between creating music that
I eye makes by itself and creating a
system that helps humans become better
musicians
okay so taking into account something
that you were saying earlier you were
describing a company growing and a
company needing to grow in order to take
risk and to make more money and to
sustain itself in the world how do we
how do we take that into account on a
finite planet
so this finite resource is on this
planet we haven't figured out how to
manufacture absolutely everything from
the molecular level up I haven't figured
out nuclear fusion we haven't figured
out how to create more energy than we
use all that stuff so does this tell us
about your thoughts on the geopolitical
and the geo economic systems of our
planet as they foster more money and
more power and more greed where do you
think that that should be in the next
decade or two as you know eight people
have as much wealth as the bottom 4
billion what do we do about this what
are kind of your thoughts about it let's
start with the fact that money is fake
money is supposed to be here to help
humanity right so it's easier for people
to pay each other with money than it is
to exchange goods it's just so much
simpler but of course it has evolved far
beyond that and became an entity with a
lot of power all by itself I think um
I'm not really in the business of
predicting the future on large scales
but I think it's definitely a lot of
options some very pessimistic some very
optimistic perhaps the most optimistic
thing that I've heard recently I was
somebody else's idea sorry I don't
recall the name um so one of the biggest
problems we have and you're talking
about resources in particular is that
overpopulation right so we have
population growth everybody's doing well
perhaps it will all have more kids all
these companies are trying to become
better than each other and keep growing
where does this end right so one
positive trying to thought within all of
this is that as countries become more
developed population stabilized
population stabilizes exactly because
women become more empowered and for
whatever reason when women are working
full time when they are active member of
society in exactly the same way as men
which we still have a long way to go by
the way even here but ok they start
having less kids fewer and fewer
children I saw the result we have fewer
people to feed ultimately and so some
people believe that population will
stabilize hopefully before it's too late
but when it stabilizes as part of such a
positive movement as part of an
inequality movement as part of having
women being able to men that's that's a
win-win from all perspectives as far as
companies was a doctor journey in that
did the part I can look that up it was
actually it looked a video really fast
made a video I was forwarding because
he's doing that taught it to me almost
two years ago perhaps that's perhaps
that's why does yeah news fact that's
fascinating
love that yeah yeah well it's continued
where you're going another hand we can't
adopt the attitude the things are just
going to work out
let's sing is Louis and everything will
be great because sometimes it's not but
then you should have control over well I
think that's where we need to have some
more social ideals I mean it doesn't
have to be very extreme it doesn't need
to destroy our economy and you know have
everything go to waste by any stretch
but having government's help people who
are in need help people who are left
behind because the world development in
tech is just moving along so quickly is
I think a reasonable approach I mean I'm
an education I indicate people every day
and I've worked at two public
universities before teaching at Santa
Clara and I know that there's a lot a
lot that needs to be improved in the
public education system at all levels
this is not not just universities
starting with elementary school and it's
constantly underfunded and there's a lot
of people who don't end up getting the
highest quality education that they can
which is devastating to me maybe doesn't
sound like such a big deal but it is
because as a result we have an absurd
number of open positions in Silicon
Valley for data scientists for
programmers extremely high paying jobs
that we cannot fill with Americans how
absurd is that we don't put enough money
into our education system and then we
can't hire our own I'm all for hiring
immigrants but can we at least try to
educate our own not so to fill up the
positions but to give our own students
these opportunities so that's I feel
like there's a place for the free market
there the place for letting the market
do whatever it does and then there's a
place for helping people who need help
like young people teenagers there's a
place for putting more resources into
the areas of development that are needed
and right now
we're not doing so great of a job we're
doing okay we can do much better at that
I think yes steam is a really strong
field that science technology
engineering art math I think pouring
money resources effort mentorship
entrepreneurship all these different
types of fires underneath of steam
especially for kids that are you know
five years old eight years old 12 years
old things like FIRST Robotics are
really good at it I think that's that's
really gonna be a major game changer and
where we go it's not a very important
detail here when I was in Waterloo
I had solid four years of education in
computer science for years okay when I
had my first academic job in the US and
a public university which I love and has
so many so many positive things only
left because we wanted to move back to
Silicon Valley but most public
universities the computer science
education is two years this squeeze
computer science with two years and the
rest is general ed no disrespect to
general edge but then when you compete
with Canadians who have four years of
education and your people have two will
guess what's gonna happen yeah so that's
the kind of things that that need to be
looked at which I don't even know that
comp Silas tried to be squeezing it to I
thought it was for here is it it says
for on your degree but most of it it's
just when you're inside when you're a
professor teach you in general Tsin on
general two years instead of the non
generals being four but that's a big
deal yeah yeah how many years of it are
you studying yes so when you teach when
I see the details of the curriculum the
changes that you have to make the amount
of information that you flat-out lose
the amount of time that it takes it
takes time to become a computer
scientist definitely it doesn't matter
how much information can be downloaded
into students Brian it's it's a process
to become a master to become a genuinely
great at some things that's genuinely
difficult yes
and to try to squeeze most of that into
two years because of yeah various
reasons yeah that's the kind of stuff we
can we can fix we can fix that so yeah
yeah okay so that's potentially a way to
address where society is heading with
all these different technologies and how
they're potentially exacerbating wealth
inequality how do we disc
the ethical quandary around what's going
on with the finite resources on our
planet okay okay how about we ask you
about what do you think is the meaning
or the purpose of life really what's a
purpose I don't know I think I went
through a lot of a lot of changes in my
life regarding that I think right now in
my mid-30s 2035 in me congratulations
you three of the way to death ah so
delightful I think I've learned that if
I can at least get to know myself and do
some good to other people in the process
that'll be okay mm-hmm I don't I think
of I've had I've held more religious
beliefs as a child which which was very
helpful in a way maybe to believe that
there's a greater purpose that could be
easily summarized and there's a daddy
that's going to make sure that
everything works out well out there in
space
I cannot have in having married an
atheist mice autism
my son don't have evolved significantly
just think that there's a lot of beauty
in this world a lot of truths to be
learned a lot of a lot of things to
experience and not experience in a kind
of simple sense of pleasures I don't get
a lot of satisfaction from just you know
eating chocolate or other things that
are supposed to be pure pleasure or like
lying down on the beach but I get for
whatever reason my brain has been
designed in a way that I get absolutely
immense pleasure from discovering new
things yeah and I've learned more and
more throughout my life to listen to
what my heart tells me to do to trust in
my own intuition and to form my life in
a way that Alliance was Who I am very
very deep inside and it'll probably take
me the rest of my life to unravel that
yeah that's the thing the closest that
I've come to understanding life in a
very broad sense
yeah that's I love I loved what you said
my brains also as much as it is wired
for loving sunsets and beaches and
helping people and all that good stuff
when it comes up to this new moment of
discovery and it goes AHA point-eight
when that happens there's not very many
things that are better than that feeling
and then taking that moment of AHA and
sharing it with other people which is
why we do this so we can share these aha
moments and these great conversations
inspire people to build the future the
guide one more thought about you
actually another friend of mine shared
the idea that the world can be recursive
which means that we are part of this
planet in as much as little cells are
part of our body yeah and I think it's
wonderful such as neurons are part of
our brain part of a galaxy galaxies are
part of the universe part of this
incredible universe right I think that
cells in my body are a part of something
greater and in that same way we are part
of something greater as well the human
experiment yeah see how it turns out oh
homeboys are though I think so
you were mentioning the most beautiful
thing in the world what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world
that's a really profound question um I
think in contrast to everything will be
discussed right now I think it's what
comes to mind is my relationship with my
son tell us why
you know I was on I was pregnant with
Alex towards the end of my master's so I
actually had my kid right around the
same time that started my PhD and I used
to tell people it's hard work yeah I
used to tell them there's and then of
course we were raising a small baby
while I was getting my entire PhD yeah
and nobody believes me but it's so much
harder to raise a child than it was to
do a PhD but I'll enormous gap I think
if five of these PhDs or easily then
then to raise a human yeah and that bond
which I'm sure has evolved evolutionary
because it's sort of such a good purpose
able to for us as a species to survive
it's a bond that I have with my child it
can't be compared to anything else
it's our SOT and I'm miles away
everything else yeah
beautiful I love that okay now that is
crazy I don't think you know so many
people just birth children and they
don't even realize that they have to be
the god to the child and raise the child
into the world really well and that that
work is very tough work it's it's
important for you to do it well so that
way the world is flourishing and not
suffering from people having kids and
that it's more difficult than five PhDs
I like that cause I don't have that but
definitely more difficult in one page
what difficult than anything I've ever
done is is is part of that do to you
molding the mind of Alex into the world
some of it is really simple that you
know come as a surprise to all new
parents and be included which is that
being fair every minute of every day for
a newborn is just insanely hard even if
the child is thank God healthy and
although we did we had a I'll just
briefly mention wait a scare with
remember during h1n1 when that was
happening my one and a half year old
cottage one and one and I remember being
in the hospital very sick was of course
I caught everything that he had having
pneumonia I'm being completely unaware
that I was sick at all
huh she just so focused on his health
that yeah he was like an actual risk he
was one and a half years old yeah um but
it's it's a little things but there's
just so many little things and you know
um uncle working mother pretty much
always took a small break to to raise
him until for a few months after he was
born but then I've always been a working
parent and you know there are
stay-at-home parents who do a lot more
because they spent so much more time so
I mean I even have no right to compare
myself to how much they do I was just so
being pregnant
you're not giving versus a one moment
raising a small baby and then just the
bond that the nature of the relationship
without having to try at all it's just
how I naturally feel about my son he's a
completely in a category of its own no
not to be fair it's early years that are
really hard he's nine years old right
now and it's it has been much easier for
a long time but but that bond the
quality of the bond I mean it only gets
stronger with time Wow it's important to
you know for people to hear that it's to
have that strong bond with your child
and that it is one of these most
profound realizations and experiences of
your life but at the same time I've been
you know I've been really weighing that
of like having a child and what it would
be like to do that process I've been
weighing that with the like you describe
the amount of energy and time and
everything that goes into that versus
the energy and time that could go into
building value into the world for the
other brothers and sisters on the planet
and there's a really tough thing to
compare those two things and figure out
which one brings more meaning it's a
personal thing that you've been
questioning I think um I think it's
important to note that having a life you
know not having children I think is a
they said it's a very much a personal
choice and I wanted to say obviously
reasonable but the language is not even
strong enough to convey that you could
have it's always a trade-off and it was
actually a very very difficult decision
for me to stop at one mmm you guys for
sure stopping or we I've made of always
thought to myself but if I don't have
another child by 35 which is in about a
couple months from now then that's it
yeah and that if that is gonna be it so
that's we have one child and it's the
right decision for us I feel like I can
still contribute to humanity and still
do a very good job raising my one child
with your second child that would be
more difficult for sure it would be a
lot more difficult yeah and I got even
harder for you to build the lesions of
the world all these days sort of my
second child but to do this I have a
real child and there's Alex yeah I know
that it's very very different both very
time-consuming but not a fair comparison
you know oh but I think it's such a
personal decision and I think there's a
lot of pressure from society telling us
what we should be doing but it's it's
entirely up to each person around how
they want to live it in many ways and
how the one organize their family how
many kids so many private personal
decisions exactly and to be educated
about the options and what they all mean
is really important do you think that
we're alone in the cosmos
no no we're not there's no way we're
alone and come on numerically it doesn't
make sense I think that the illusion
that do we even might be alone just ties
back to humans believing that there's a
center of everything
maybe there is life right here that I
can't even perceive in order for us to
perceive life we have to share some
senses with it and we have to be close
enough so that our rather weak senses as
humans can pick them up even with all of
our technology but the cosmos is fast
there are so many galaxies and so many
planets of course there's something
well what do you what do you think that
something is like I don't know I'm not
sure that there is something that we can
never necessarily perceive okay yeah so
it's more about that what is that
intimate it's a very different dimension
what is it I think I just might not
share any senses with it you don't share
any senses yeah I think that could be
look that would be the great it's a good
way to what's a good way to put it right
if if they don't have if we can't see
them and we can't hear them but probably
not going to smell them or taste them or
touch them anytime soon right so if we
lose those two primary senses we don't
have those in common that's it yeah okay
cool
I wonder how that consciousness or that
or their their perception systems would
build out without the same senses that
we have well that's that's the issue
right so we had and maybe there are some
creatures out there is that are similar
enough to us that we could recognize
them they booked a recognize that was
life looking at how humans have a you
know how this planet has evolved
everything that's alive on it it took a
very particular path because I you know
our the computer scientist is an AI
person it's all its whole search problem
and I worked a little bit with genetic
algorithms so this could have evolved
very differently right since could have
started off differently if you if you
see de universe differently if the
initial starting point is different
you're gonna end up somewhere else but
even if you see that similarly if things
started off for the Big Bang somewhere
else was you know perhaps the cell
formed but then from there things could
have gone in a completely different path
and it would probably be very difficult
for us to hypothesize so what a very
different path would be like that
doesn't mean it doesn't exist it seems
very unlikely that things could have
evolved just in this way or even in a
way that's very similar to the way that
we have evolved even when we look at
other animals we see okay they evolve
very differently but still we are
compared to anything on another planet
amoeba or the zebra is like my sister so
it'd be something that you know might be
fundamentally different difficult for us
to to imagine because we always start
with what we're most knowing
but to jump as far as saying there is
nothing at all that's live that's
perfect to me
do you think that those other potential
beings could have simulated our universe
and we are living in a matrix are we in
a computer simulation I doubt it I think
that also ties back to humans thinking
they're the center of everything
somebody cared so much that they created
a whole complicated simulation for us so
they've like the greatest experiment
ever though
yeah we're not part of anybody's
experiment nobody cares
we need to we need to get over this this
really narcissistic view of ourselves
you know we are the only ones with
intelligence we're the only ones whose
creativity somebody bother creating a
complicated simulation to fool us and
see what we're gonna do or you know
steal our energy I found it I think all
things being equal it takes the simpler
explanation and this is an awfully
complicated explanation awesome so let's
send more people to try Alicia calm
let's get them to play with your
songwriting ai yeah it's gonna be free
for only a limited time for the next few
months and then we're gonna launch we
would love your feedback as well so if
you use it get in touch with me tell me
what you think the feedback bar right
there on Alicia yeah and I'm I'm really
excited we might even do some simulation
music with Alicia Wow
yeah let's give that a go let's see what
that ends up being well I sing for you
guys yeah yeah we maybe get a little bit
of uh we get a little taste of the Opera
one last time yeah okay give me a
sentence and I'll be Alesia giving you
and random melody events okay
okay are we that's so beautiful
Thanks oh my gosh we're so grateful to
have you on my thank you so much for
being our guest such a pleasure thank
you thank you thank you so much Alan
this has been a pleasure we'll send more
people to try Lisi comm get them to to
try all your song writing a I give you
feedback and maybe you some on
simulation there will be a lot of fun it
some of these are gone here sounds
fabulous
yes let's do it and let's keep let's
keep up these conversations with your
students about ethics about the
importance of AI in the world and
teaching them in relatable ways I think
this was a great conversation for the
viewers at home if you guys found this
useful like comment subscribe do share
with others become a patron that helps
us a lot to sustain our studio and
sustain the development of these great
conversations across the world and we'll
be coming back at you soon so stay tuned
and much love thanks for tuning in
[Music]